two weeks ago I watched on YouTube a
lecturer from MIT for free the same
lecture that would have cost X thousands
of dollars right so I think when the
dust settles higher education is going
to be revealed for the luxury brand that
it truly is and when you take away all
of the stuff that has nothing to do with
learning or connecting you're gonna be
left with a breathtakingly overpriced
product let's actually back up for a
second and talk about your foundation a
little bit because everything you're
saying right now I think does get to a
trend that I've been seeing for a while
which is I've had so many guests who
come from academia and you know so much
of our national conversation is about
outrage culture and cancel culture and
what's happening at colleges and now
because of YouTube's average people and
I mean that in the best sense of average
all of us can can watch incredible
thinkers give lectures you can watch
Jordan Peterson lectures on YouTube for
free and maybe get more information from
that then you can from a semester or
that you're paying 25 grand for so talk
about your foundation and and sort of
can you just relate that a little bit to
what you see happening with higher ed
relative to if you have a trade right
now it's like you are essential again in
the best sense of essential that's not
we're not putting down the non-essential
maybe we can come up with a better word
for it right now well we should because
everything has a season and part of the
reason we're locked in this endless
feedback loop of nonsense is because
we're in love with cookie cutter advice
and so we dispense it with certainty and
this is what politicians do to be
elected they have to they they have to
say the thing that's going to resonate
with the most people and so they wind up
they wind up retrenching two bromines
and platitudes and tropes that's what
safety first is that's that's why Cuomo
said no measure no matter how draconian
or drastic could be deemed unjustifiable
if it saves a single life reasonable
people reasonable people know that's a
lie
reasonable people know that when United
Airlines or American Airlines says here
at blankety-blank airline your safety is
our priority we don't really believe
that because seconds later they invite
us to strap ourselves into an aluminum
tube and defy gravity at 700 miles an
hour okay the truth is on the back of
the ticket rules of carriage read that
and you'll hear the truth so we don't
tell people the truth in a lot of ways
but when we lie to them now
the consequences are catastrophic so
we've got to get past the cookie cutter
advise the bromides in the platitudes if
there's a silver lining to answer your
question and I think there probably are
a couple of them I don't know when we'll
see them but the way we learn surely has
to be among them what we're doing right
now
I mean opinions will vary obviously but
this is meaning no no you know you know
everyone's on board what we're doing
right now trust me I mean you were
having a grown-up conversation
I don't feel rushed to provide you with
a soundbite you're you listen more than
you talk which most guests most hosts
don't do so you know you're you're doing
a bunch of stuff right and two weeks ago
I watched on YouTube a lecturer from MIT
for free the same lecture that would
have cost X thousands of dollars right
so I think when the dust settles higher
education is going to be revealed for
the luxury brand that it truly is and
when you take away all of the stuff that
has nothing to do with learning or
connecting you're gonna be left with a
breathtakingly overpriced product and
when you look at schools like Harvard
who didn't refund their the the tuitions
for canceled classes they didn't even
refund the room and board you know well
people are gonna get used to this screen
they already are but I think more and
more are gonna take deeper dives into
more interesting ponds and they're gonna
find big thinkers with easily accessible
ideas who are exponentially more
interesting than professors and soon I
hope our
obscene love affair with credentialing
is going is going to stop and we're
we're going to pause in every imaginable
way and look at what is essential not
just in workers or in work but in
education in food and fun you know
everything is going to be forced through
a different filter and I wish I were
smarter to say specifically you know how
that's going to come out but um you
never get to see how the sausage is
truly made you know in our industry
really or in or in any until the dust
settles so we've got to get through it
but I don't know that we're gonna
recognize the airline industry I don't
know that we're gonna recognize higher
education I don't know that we're gonna
recognize exercise everything is going
to change some things for the better
some things not but that level of
uncertainty through all of it is the
reason why everybody's walking around
like an extra in the walking dead right
now waiting for clarity yeah so even
though we maybe didn't want this I'm
pretty sure nobody wanted this to happen
but to all of your points that lead to
the silver lining of this do you think
that in a weird way this was almost
necessary to get like it almost feels
like the old world was just sort of
caught in some weird I guess the Frog
and the pot kind of thing like our
institutions were not working properly
we know how much money we were sending
kids out into the real world with debt
that the jobs weren't quite there that
if anything maybe this toppled enough of
the of the just the grunge and grit that
was on the machine maybe it chipped off
enough that we can start building some
new stuff so that's actually good I
think so look I I liken it to
I mean every major transformative moment
in your own life was probably preceded
by something akin to a splat sometimes
things have to go splat you know
sometimes in little ways sometimes in
big ways this is a biggie this is the
biggest thing I've ever lived through in
terms of a you know a transformational
event and so I again I I don't know how
it's going to shake out but but yeah the
Machine just got shook we just something
grabbed us by the lapels with big
muscular hands and shook really it's
still shaking us and we're we're trying
to make sense of the shaking while our
glasses are flying off of our head and
the change is coming out of our but
we're still being shook but here's the
here's the thing I mentioned this I
think - Glenn Beck the other day you
know the thing nobody is thinking about
when with regard to a premature opening
versus and unnecessary sequestration is
what happened to the Brits in 39 right I
mean Hitler dropped a lot of bombs on
London every day day after day day after
day after day for weeks they stayed in
hunkered in the bunker in the air-raid
shelters and then about three weeks into
it they started venturing out bombs were
still falling right started opening
shops the bombs were still falling they
opened the schools the bombs were still
falling they were cleaning up now I'm
not saying for a second that we ought to
do anything premature but I'm saying
that no matter what we do first is going
to feel premature doesn't matter what it
is it's going to feel reckless it has to
by definition but the thing is what
really drove the Brits out of their
bunkers i I wasn't there I don't really
know but the
I've read my sense of it is they got
bored look at that got bored of being
terrorized
just said no and and they had enough
time as horrific as it was they had
enough time to let it sit for a minute
and there's no way you're coming out
after day 2 or 5 or 8 or 12 14 mmm 20
mm-hmm
right and so it's very personal and
there's a herd mentality just as surely
as there's a herd immunity and the first
ones to go
we'll look reckless and crazy but then
others will follow and then pretty soon
you're a guy who gets behind the wheel
of your car and drives across the state
knowing full well that 40,000 people are
going to die this year as a result of
traffic fatalities but you get in and
you and you strap up and look you do a
lot of things I mentioned Cuomo earlier
and I'll circle back if he really
believed it if you really believed it
then you might get together just get
together with the governor's and say
look we're lowering the speed limits to
20 we're all wearing helmets and we're
outlawing left turns you could say
40,000 lives this year but you won't do
that because we have baked the risk into
our lives and at base we are safety
third kind of people if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about lifestyles instead
of non-stop yelling check out our
lifestyle playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out our full episode
playlist they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell